so they're going to affect your  testosterone um estrogen progesterone  there's no good evidence this happens  this study actually found that it  doesn't happen they applied ten percent  of three chemical sunscreens oxybenzone  octanoxide and 4mbc all over some  volunteers for a week and measured their  hormone levels they found only very  small differences that look like natural  variations we observe no biologically  significant effects on hormone levels  there are in vitro and animal studies  that found sunscreens could potentially  be endocrine disruptors but things that  happen in cells and in mice when they  eat an ingredient don't necessarily  happen in humans when we put it on our  skin in the amounts in sunscreen as we  can see in the study so wreaking havoc  on a person's body is  a bit of a stretch